I don't like to be overly dictatorial
towards shows that I like but ya know
these would all be bad ideas so as of
the time of my recording this my most
viewed video is and has been for a while
five things that doctor who needs to
stop doing and I've kind of felt like I
am overdue to sort of look at the other
side of that that video obviously as you
can tell from the title talked about
things that doctor who has been doing
that I wanted it to stop this one um I
you might think the flip of that is me
saying things they should definitely do
except I don't have as firm bethought
about what I think the show should do I
mean there are characters I'd like to
see come back I've done you know some
stuff revolving around that and there'll
be some more like that but this time I
want to talk about four things I don't
ever want the show to do
why four and not five because I couldn't
think of a fifth that I actually cared
all that much about and I don't like to
pad my list so we're gonna talk about
four and we're gonna start with a
spin-off on Gallifrey I have talked
before about how I generally don't like
things set on Gallifrey in the first
place because the either due to the
limitations of the budget and what they
can realize or to the limitations of the
imagination of the writers it always
ends up demystifying the place it always
ends up making it seem really mundane we
go to Gallifrey on things in episodes
like the deadly assassin and look at
that they have public television and
news announcers that's weird and like
this it's just so mundane it's so
terrestrial it's so of our world
I want a sense of otherness of alienness
of being wavy I'm not necessarily better
but like beyond the sorts of things that
you and I do here on earth
and we almost never get that or you know
like hell-bent they've got they've got
barns like made of wood and a chunk of
their population dresses like his little
house on the prairie what so there's my
initial gut reaction to look it almost
never do when we get more information
about Gallifrey doesn't do anything
other than make you go oh well that's
really very ordinary
I mean Gallifrey the Time Lords
generally are at their best the less we
know about them when they showed up
again in the end of time you know we got
a sense of the threat but they still
felt otherworldly they felt big it was
actually fairly reminiscent of their
first official appearance as a society
in the war games the second doctor's era
where we know almost nothing about them
and it made them so intimidating but you
know III don't think you know between
not having a heck of a lot of faith that
they're gonna be able to consistently
give us something that isn't just gonna
continue to demystify them and also
looking at things like Krypton you know
I I don't I don't think there's anything
good to be mined out of this because
again like I said they Gallifrey works
best the less we know about it and then
I'm gonna double down on this and say it
would be even worse if it was like a
prequel dealing with the doctor like
super young in his first regeneration
like before he was even old enough to
look like William Hartnell like that
would be awful like you know never never
ever ever ever do that I mean never do
like a Gallifrey spin-off in the first
place really double never ever do that
because it it runs is a classic prequel
problem you can't actually develop the
character very much if at all and even
if you do develop it's got to be in a
very rigid way because he cannot end up
more developed than how he was when we
started following him in the actual
Doctor Who show which means you either
have to have him have no development or
have it be really
slow or you've got to have them start
out so far away from what we recognize
them as that you can eventually get
there over the long haul and it's just
it's gonna be painful it's not gonna
work and again again I don't think
demystifying the doctor to that degree
is a good idea either
so number three and I know a lot of you
are gonna disagree with me on this but
hear me out never make the doctor ginger
I'm serious
I'm not joking at this point it has
become such a running thing of the
doctor wanting to be ginger not becoming
ginger that if they ever do it I think
needs to be the very last incarnation of
the show if not like the very last
episode like like the show's ending and
we have the doctor regenerate into a
form that it's presumed goes off and
continues to have adventures past the
the running of the TV show like have
that one be gin you're fine because at
this point I treat the doctor becoming
ginger like he will they won't they
relationships in most other TV shows at
what point do those shows go downhill
when you answer the question of well
they won't they because first of all the
answer is always yes they will but when
you eventually get them together the
entire dynamic changes and you lose a
big part of the oh well okay they did
why am I still here and not that I'm
saying the doctor trying to become
ginger is that fundamental to the makeup
of the show I'm not trying to oversell
it of that but it's it's all that same
nature I don't think that I think that
the continued frustration that he has at
not being ginger is God is going to be
more entertaining than the very brief
pop you'll get by finally doing it I'll
stick in asterisks on this and say if
they ever do make the doctor ginger I
really want the reaction to be that the
doctor looks at Amerigo xym ginger I
don't like it and then never bring it up
again so but I really rather they just
didn't do
number two make the doctor earthbound
now I know there is precedent for this
most of the Third Doctor's era was very
terrestrially locked he almost never
went to other planets and so I
understand this precedent for this but I
mean there was also what they were what
they were doing with the show at that
point that made sense basically they
wanted to make the doctor more like
James Bond that's why he did the
Venusian Aikido that's why the master
was like a Bond villain like that's why
the doctor had a car and you know the
the gadgets like the hoobmobile like
that is why all that stuff was in was
there to give it more of a James Bond
flavor but it then moved off from it and
at this point especially for how long
the show's been around I what a big part
of what I love about Doctor Who is the
breadth of possibilities is the fact
that they he can go or heap she I I have
to get used to that now that the fact or
I'll just say the doctor has on his care
as I can and avoid the gender terms that
the doctor can go anywhere and any when
I love that breadth of possibilities I
don't I'd like and I've seen more than a
few people float the idea of maybe with
Jodie Whitaker's first season because it
looked like possibly the TARDIS kicked
her out that maybe her whole first
series is gonna be like trying to
reclaim the TARDIS and she'll be stuck
on earth and oh my god I hope not
I hope not I don't want the show to be
that limited for that length of a period
of time and that's not even me saying
that it's impossible to get good stories
out of that but I would also argue that
anything that you get out of doing a
long-form show up in terrestrial Browns
story ie
the more character on sort of
progression and dynamic growth or
whatever like between the doctor and the
companion so the doctor has of the
supporting cast you can still get that
and having them move to
locations and times of planets and stuff
and you could still write that same
stuff in being earthbound you makes you
have to do that because you don't you
don't have you can't go off in space for
stuff but that's that's not making an
earthbound and restricting it is not the
only way to be able to do that kind of
stuff you can still do that without
making those show earthbound I just
don't I don't like those kinds of
excessive restrictions being put on the
show because this show appeals to my n
our nine-year-old the you know the part
of me that wants to just make believe
anything and the fewer possibilities
they are sort of the less interested I
am so I know this is idea some people
want and I've seen it the idea floated I
really don't want the show to do this
one though and finally number one and
this is a big one like some of these I I
will grant it is there is like vaguely
possible there was ever so slight sliver
of a way that it can be made to work
this one no I'm drawing a hard line on
this no never
the Doctor Who TV show should never ever
have the doctor regenerate into an actor
that has already played the part now a
couple things I have to point out about
this one I do know that canon wise in
the show they have opened up that
possibility
due to Tom Baker's appearance in the day
of the doctor which is not something I
was against I still like that but what I
liked about that is because obviously
they're not gonna cast Tom Baker again
in this part but what I liked about it
is to me that just implied the
endlessness of this show because we will
actually never see the character ever
regenerate into this act to her again
because like I said he's never gonna
play the part again which means we're
never gonna reach the end which means
doctor who effectively goes on forever
even if the show ends again we will
never truly reach an end point for this
character that's why I was in favor of
that scene aside from the fact that Tom
Baker was just wonderful and delightful
but by implying that Tom Baker was a
later regeneration of the doctor it
opens up the possibility that Matt Smith
could come back David Tennant could come
back you know any of the living doctors
feasibly but I mean realistically those
would be the two that people will be
clambering for at least at this point
and I think that more than anything else
more than any other things I've i've
named more than almost anything that i
can think of would be the death knell of
this show because that would be a point
at which the show would cease evolving
the show would stop trying to be
anything other than fanservice
because the instant the show does and
this show already can get very tied up
in its own history and continuity and
minutia sometimes decently sometimes to
his detriment but doing something like
that having Matt Smith or David Tennant
or Christopher Eccleston or any previous
actors play the part be the doctor again
not like here are some extra adventures
you didn't know about but like at the
end of Jody Whitaker's once she
regenerates into Mass Smith that might
be the thing that would make me stop
watching Doctor Who because at that
point remember I said about breadth of
possibilities endless possibilities at
that point that feels like a bigger
restriction impossibilities than
anything else and what I mean by that is
the show is no longer looking forward it
is only looking back it will be only
looking into its own history it'll only
be gazing into its own navel it is a
regressive move it is it would be a
deliberate attempt to try and be
something that it was before instead of
figuring out what it can now be and
doctor who has always been a show that
has evolved through the casting of the
doctors to the changes in aesthetics
through the changes in the creative team
and shifts and priorities and the
writing the show has always been evolved
sometimes for the better sometimes for
the worse and sometimes they do bring
back older elements and that's fine but
when the you literally start putting the
old face back on the character again
that's when there's nowhere forward to
go anymore
now you're just swimming in nostalgia
and that might break me if they if this
show ever did that and that is why I
think that is the number one thing this
show should never ever do so that's my
list for things that doctor who should
not ever do what do you think are some
things they should never do and please
have them be things they haven't already
done don't just be snarky and go oh cast
a woman but they did it like look guys
it happened okay give tell me something
the show has not actually done yet that
you think it should never do whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it all the
stuff to do like subscribe or man pager
and follow me on Twitter listen my
podcast by t-shirt links for all this
stuff is down in the description and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]